rouge est une pub est un rêve mais si
heureuse au mont cher 3 ouverte au bâton
qui a nécessité deux autres fermiers eux
aussi moins denses et run il faut qu'ils
aillent d'urgence cres et zébulon
bonjour chez apple c'est bonjour mon
cher petit coin allons vite donc c'est
fini ce gouffre de que sous peu en
voiture c'est l'amorcé admiration au
départ
serge danot pollux eux rentrer dans
l'histoire du cinéma a bien sûr
absolument henry avec un long métrage
que vous avez quand laurence et depuis
combien de temps eh bien elle est
commencé depuis deux ans exactement ça
représente beaucoup de travail coct
mille personnes y travaillent
trente personnes dont le main et donc le
temps que vous y avez mis jusqu'ici
c'est à dire deux ans de préparation et
10 mois de tournage absolue tous les
jours on tournait certaines journées 5 à
6 secondes les bonnes journées 30 40
secondes ça dépend beaucoup de décors
aussi énormément de décors plusieurs
camions et la musique la musique aussi
été fait je crois d'une façon assez
sensationnel puisque nous n'avons pas
lésiné sur la musique nous avons pris
100 musiciens pour orchestrer cette
musique et jose basilic et le grand chef
d'orchestre
cette formation qui veut souligner aussi
ce que c'est une entreprise régionale
absolument oui absolument puisque mon
dieu tout été fait ici autant sur le
plan scénario décor interprète les
interprètes sont sont tous des dentelles
très connus tels que christian réel jeu
cela a fait les dialogues que ce que
nous avons encore tardieu cetera il faut
pas effleuré le sujet mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner une petite idée
du thème très rapide à mais bien sûr
c'est tout simplement faux luxe qui
un nouvel ennemi qui est le chat bleu un
chat bleu qui veut être le maître d'un
paisible et lui s'aperçoit que c'est un
chat qui est pas très très très gentil
voilà lancé pollux et le chat et le
chablais tout simplement
et à quand le rendez vous sur le grand
écran et bien pour noël pour les faits
de même pour le faire l'objet d'autres
femmes dès 10h au rang de la moitié de
ce prêt chez du village oliva